I know I think couples therapy and I
love it do you do you feel like it's
it's easy are there do you have like big
revelations where you're like oh my god
Eureka you've said it you know like are
there like we walk out of it feeling
good but we're not always able to apply
it like are you going to be really good
about like applying everything that no
like for us like we I mean we've been
doing therapy couples therapy since like
pretty much the beginning of this this
round of our relationship because we've
been together before in the past so like
we've been doing couples therapy every
week for like three years Wow I think
that's important sometimes more like if
there's like an issue um sometimes more
and honestly like I think every couples
should do it and like I think you know
for us we're at the point now where like
of course we still get into like the
cycle of arguing and and you know we'll
just like never resolve anything because
like we're both just you know in the
cycle but like we've learned I think at
this point we like are really good at
like shelfing a problem and we're like
let's just talk about it in therapy this
week and then we can just and like just
knowing that like we both feel validated
and will eventually be heard so for us
it's like really easy to like move on
with our day and keep getting along and
not like fall apart over this one issue
because it's like there's a time and
place for us to both be heard and we'll
both feel validated and we will like
fine empathy in each other and like
we've I think learned to like trust the
process as corny yeah I knew I could
trust the process when in the beginning
of beginning of quarantine you know when
things were really kind of uncertain
still like people didn't know how
contagious this thing was and Bobby even
in the beginning of lockdown he kind of
just wanted to go about his life as
usual like he wanted to and then I was
worried about him I was Jenny worried
like he is a smoker I don't want him to
get sick whatever whatever so that was
really like a heavy thing in my mind so
I kept so to keep him in the house
I would buy everything he wanted like if
it was lumen
Pizza delivered from Chicago if he
wanted like you know restaurant quality
katsu I would cook everything from
scratch like pasta from scratch like
bucatini from scratch everything to make
him want to stay and when we went to
therapy and I said you know I I feel
like I'm trying so hard to get him to
stay so I'm buying I'm like basically a
[ __ ] Michelin star restaurant and
then she asked Bobby she was like what's
more important she's like what's making
you stay is what she asked him she's
like it's all of her doing that making
you want to stay and he goes yes I want
to stay because she's providing this
like all this food and stuff she's like
then I'm worried about your relationship
because if her fears and her concerns
and her feelings are not enough for you
to stay but pizza is enough for you to
stay you should just end it now and I
was like oh my god oh that's so real so
so I started ordering my own stuff belly
I have six pizzas coming in two days and
I have also clam chowder from New
England coming in the bread so I just
sponsors because we really really we
burn one final question so on what is it
has it been a cuz I haven't really
talked to you since you had your baby
has it been a life changer like you know
how everyone says her